one of the most exciting developments
were sequences sequence models has been
the rise of very accurate speech
recognition we're nearing the end of the
course but I want to take just a couple
videos to give you a sense of how these
sequences sequence models are applied to
audio data such as to speech so what is
the speech recognition problem you're
given an audio clip X and your job is to
automatically find a text transcript Y
so an audio clip if you plot it looks
like this the horizontal axis here is
time and what a microphone does is it
really measures ministy changes in air
pressure and the way you're hearing my
voice right now is that your ear is
detecting little changes in air pressure
probably generated either by your
speakers or by a headset and then audio
clip like this plots you know basically
air pressure against time and if this
audio clip is of me saying the quick
brown fox then hopefully a speech
recognition algorithm can input that
audio clip and output that transcript
and because even the human ear doesn't
process raw waveforms but the human ear
has physical structures that measures
the amounts of intensity of different
frequencies there is a common
pre-processing step for audio data is to
run your raw audio clip and generate a
spectrogram so this is a plot where the
horizontal axis is time and the vertical
axis is frequencies and the intensity of
different colors shows the amount of
energy so how loud is the sound at
different frequencies at different times
and so these types of spectrograms
or you might also hear people talk about
filter Bank outputs is often commonly
applied pre-processing step before audio
is passed into a learning algorithm and
the human ear does a computation pretty
similar to the
pre-processing step so one of the most
exciting trends in speech recognition is
that once upon a time speech recognition
systems used to be built using phonemes
and these were I want to say hand
engineered basic units of sound so the
quick brown fox would be represented as
phonemes I'm going to simplify a bit but
you say there has a duck and sound and
quick as a cup and what a sound and
linguist used to write out these basic
units of sound and try the Greek
language down into these basic units of
cell so Brown right these aren't the
official phonemes which are written with
more complicated notation but but
linguist used to hypothesize that
writing down audio in terms of these
basic units of sound called phonemes
would be the best way to do speech
recognition but with end-to-end deep
learning we're finding that phony
representations are no longer necessary
but instead you can build systems that
input an audio clip and directly
outputting the transcript without
needing to use a hand engineer absent
ations
like these one of the things that made
this possible was going to much larger
data sense so so academic data sets on
speech recognition might be as a 300
hours and in academia of the thousand
our data sets of trance Drive audio
would be considered reasonable size so a
lot of research has been done a lot of
research papers have been written on
data sense there are several thousand
dollars but the best commercial systems
are now trained on over 10,000 hours and
sometimes over a hundred thousand
dollars of audio and is really moving to
much larger audio data set transcribe
audio DSS with both x and y together
with deep learning algorithms that has
driven a lot of progress in speech
recognition so how do you build a speech
recognition system in the last video we
talked about the attention
so one thing you could do is actually do
that where on the horizontal axis you
take in different time frames of the
audio input and then you have an
attention model we tried to output the
transcript like the quick brown fox or
whatever was said one other method that
seems to work well is to use the CDC
costs of speech recognition CT c stands
for connectionist temporal
classification and is due to Alex gray
San Diego Fernandez Faustina Gomez and
urine schmidhuber so here's the idea
let's say the audio clip was was of
someone saying the quick brown fox we're
going to use a we're going to use the
neural network structured like this with
an equal number of input X's and output
Y's and I've drawn a simple of one
uni-directional for only RNN for this
but in practice this will usually be a
bi-directional LS TM or bi-directional
gru and usually a deeper model but
notice that the number of time steps
here is very large and in speech
recognition usually the number of input
time steps is much bigger than the
number of output time steps so for
example if you have 10 seconds of audio
and your features come at a hundred
Hertz so under samples per second then a
10-second audio clip would end up with a
thousand inputs right so this 100 Hertz
times 10 seconds ends up with a thousand
inputs but your output might not have a
thousand alphabets might not have a
thousand characters so what did you do
the ctc cost function allows the RNN to
generate an output like this TTT does a
special character called a blank
character which in the writers are
underscore here each blank e-e-e blank
blank blank and then maybe a space right
like this so that's a space and then
blank blank blank QQ q blank blank and
this is considered a correct output for
the first part of the space quick with
the cue and the basic rule for the CTC
cost function is to collapse repeated
characters not separated by blank so to
be clearer I'm using this underscore to
denote the special blank character and
that's different than the space
character so there is a space here
between the and quick so I should upload
a space but by collapsing repeated
characters not separated by blank
it actually collapsed the sequence into
t-h-e
and then space and Q and this allows the
your network to have a thousand outputs
by repeating characters a lot of times
or inserting a bunch of blank characters
and still end up with a much shorter
output text transcript so this phrase
here the quick brown fox including
spaces as she has 19 characters and if
somehow the new network is forced
upwards of thousand characters by
allowing the network to insert blanks
and repeated characters and can still
represent this 19 character output which
is 1000 outputs values of Y so this
paper by Alex grace as well as by dues
deep speech speech recognition system
which I was involved in use this idea to
build effective speech recognition
systems so I hope that gives you a rough
sense of how speech recognition models
were attention line models work and CTC
models work and present two different
options for how to go about building
these systems now today building a
effective or a production scale speech
recognition system is a pretty
significant effort it requires a very
large data set but what I like to do in
the next video share of you how you can
build a trigger word detection system or
a keyword detection system which is
actually much easier and condemned
even a smaller or more reasonable amount
of data so let's talk about that in the
next video